Dockers are an interesting group they're
not all cut from the same cloth they're
not as homogeneous a group as men who
commit serial sexual homicide you know
they're women stalkers they're men
stalkers and there are stalkers who are
very lonely and very eager to affect
some kind of attachment oftentimes to a
person that's more famous or powerful
than they are and so they will find out
where the person lives and go around and
follow them look around their house and
things and sometimes they may even
commit a crime you know of breaking and
entering or trying to hurt that person
there are other stalkers who will try to
get back at a lover who's rejected them
the case of Farley Richard Farley in
California for example who was in he
fell in love with the love is the right
word with a co-worker in his firm that
he worked for and when she rejected him
she rejected him after he said if you
don't love me I'll kill you well I mean
that's not the way to a woman's heart so
he then would find out where she lived
he would put little messages on her car
was pretty scary and finally he being a
gun nut
brought a bunch of guns to the workplace
and he killed seven people he tried to
kill her also but he the bullet hit her
shoulder and she's survived so that was
a combination mass murder and stalking
because he stalked her for a long time
before he erupted to the murder but
there are other men particularly who are
certifiably insane or crazy like for
example that one that a stalk the
actress Olivia newton-john he was a
paranoid schizophrenic who had
ultimately killed members of his family
but he would go out to California and
trying in order to form some kind of a
relationship with this exalted and for
him totally unreachable figure of this
beautiful woman the same by the way has
happened with Richard Bardot
any ORS in California who stalked
Rebecca Schaeffer the actress went to
her door after the Department of Motor
Vehicles gave him the address and so on
and he shot her to death why because he
thought that he that she loved him
because she sent him a photograph of
herself you know the way you send a
request to an actress please send me a
picture and she sends probably a
thousand pictures to her fans and in his
crazy mind because he was schizophrenic
he thought that she really loved him and
then when he saw her in a movie where
she seemed to be acting the part of a
woman who loved other guys and was
undressing and kissing and so on
he thought she's betrayed me and he then
went and killed her so there was a
stalker that actually killed the object
of his affection there other ones that
stalk tennis stars and follow them
wherever they are and things of that
sort but there are there often people
who were hungry for attachment but then
who know no bounds in there's no break
system preventing them from bothering
and pestering or even sometimes harming
the object of their interest